I REMAIN CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC
THAT THEY WILL DO THE RIGHT
THING, AND DO IT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE."
HERE IS THE REACTION FROM FLOOR
TO CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ, AND
MICHAEL BASS, FORMER WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP MORAN'S
PREVIOUS, LET'S START WITH THE
SHOW, THE CONGENITAL
LIAR.
MATT GAETZ, TELL EVER AND HOW
CORRUPT TOMORROW IS, ESPECIALLY
COMPARED TO HOW REPUBLICANS
TREATED BILL CLINTON, BILL
CLINTON'S LAWYERS, AND THE
MINORITY PARTY IN 1998.
>> IT'S OBVIOUS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT DEMOCRATS CAN'T WIN
A FAIR FIGHT BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT ENGAGE IN ANY
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
AND SO YOU SEE DEMOCRATS DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO LIMIT OUR
ABILITY TO CALL WITNESSES, LIMIT
OUR ABILITY TO YIELD TIME TO
MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE
DEPOSITIONS, BUT ALL OF THE
DIRTY TRICKS FROM ADAM SCHIFF'S
BAG OF TRICKS WILL NOT CHANGE A
FEW FUNDAMENTAL FACTS.
FIRST, THAT WE CAN SEE THE
TRANSCRIPT, AND THERE IS NO
CONDITIONALITY ON ANY AID.
SECOND, THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY, THE ACTUAL
PEOPLE ON THE CALL, SAID THERE
WAS NO PRESSURE.
THIRD, AT THE TIME OF THE CALL,
THE UKRAINIANS WERE NOT AWARE OF
ANY DELAY ON THEIR AID,
WHATSOEVER.
FOURTH AND FINALLY, THE EIGHT
THAT BARACK OBAMA WITHHELD WAS
DELIVERED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WITHOUT ANY
BEGINNING OF ANY INVESTIGATIONS
INTO BURISMA OR HUNTER BIDEN.
NOW, I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WILL
TRY TO DO ALL THEY CAN TO HAVE
CONJECTURE AROUND THOSE FACTS,
BUT NOTHING CHANGES THEM, AND
THAT MEANS THERE SHOULDN'T BE AN
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, REINCE,
IT'S AMAZING -- I WILL ASK A
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND A LITTLE --
BUT THEY HAVE ACTUALLY MADE THIS
GUY, WHO WAS COMPROMISED, THIS
GUY, WHO IS A FACT WITNESS IN
THIS CASE, THIS GUY WHO -- BY
THE WAY, HE LIED ABOUT THE
TRANSCRIPT, SO THAT WHEN HE OR
SHE WAS READING -- HE ACTUALLY
MADE UP A FAKE TRANSCRIPT.
OH, WE DID HAVE CONTACT WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER -- HE WAS LYING
ABOUT THAT.
HE'S LIED FOR THREE YEARS ABOUT
RUSSIA.
HOW IS IT THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
DUMB ENOUGH TO PICK THAT
COMPROMISED GUY, FACT WITNESS,
TO BE THEIR LEADER IN THIS?
>> WELL, IT'S CREATED ANOTHER
ENVIRONMENT HERE, SEAN.
IT'S CREATED THE ENVIRONMENT OF
TOTAL PARTISANSHIP.
AND AS LONG AS THERE IS TOTAL
PARTISANSHIP TO 300,000 PEOPLE
OUT THERE IN THE BATTLEGROUND
STATES THAT NEED TO DECIDE THIS
THING, ARE GOING TO LOOK AT IT
AS SOME POLITICAL GAME THAT IS
LED BY A POLITICAL PERSON LIKE
ADAM SCHIFF.
NOW, MATT GAETZ NAILED IT.
BY THE WAY, HE DID A GREAT JOB
BY BLOWING UP THE STAR CHAMBER
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO AND EXPOSING
ALL OF THIS.
BUT I THINK IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO DO WHAT
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ DID JUST DID,
NARROW IT DOWN TO EXACTLY WHAT
IT IS.
ON ITS WORST DAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE A
NONCONSUMMATED WRONGDOING.
AT WORST, SO WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
THE MONEY WAS RELEASED, WHICH IT
WAS.
SO FINALLY, WHAT DO WE HAVE THAT
IS ON TRIAL?
WHAT WE HAVE ON TRIAL IS THE
STATE OF MIND OF THE PRESIDENT.
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO CONSUMMATED
ACTION, BECAUSE MONEY WAS
RELEASED.
>> Sean: THEY NEVER MENTIONED
BONNIE.
NEVER MENTIONED IT
>> MONEY WAS RELEASED.
BECAUSE NOW YOU HAVE A TRIAL,
THE STATE OF MIND OF THE
PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE TO ALLOW
THAT STATE OF MIND TO BE IN
FOCUS, WHICH MEANS YOU HAVE TO
BRING THE BIDEN ISSUE INTO PLAY.
YOU HAVE TO BRING THE CORRUPTION
INTO PLAY.
AND LET ALL OF THAT PLAY OUT.
BUT AS CONGRESSMAN GAETZ SAID,
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO CALL A WITNESS LIKE HUNTER
BIDEN AND JOE BIDEN, TO THE
STANDS AND SAY WHAT WAS
REALLY GOING ON IN UKRAINE?
BECAUSE IT'S RELEVANCE TO THE
PRESIDENT'S STATE OF MIND, THEN
YOU ARE AND HAVE A TRIAL.
>> Sean: THAT'S ONE OF THE
BEST ANALYSIS I'VE EVER SEEN.
LOOK, YOU KNOW WISCONSIN BETTER
THAN ANYBODY.
HOW WILL THE 300,000 IN THOSE
SIX STATE THAT YOU MENTIONED
REACTS TO THIS WITCH HUNT?
NO DUE PROCESS, SHOW PUT ON BY
THIS CORRUPT, COMPROMISED LIAR,
IN THIS CASE?
>> IF THE PRESIDENT WINS EITHER
WISCONSIN OR MICHIGAN OR
PENNSYLVANIA, ONE OF THE THREE,
HE GETS REELECTED.
IN WISCONSIN, THIS IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL IS NOT PLAYING OUT WELL AT
ALL.
IN FACT, YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
MARQUETTE POLL OF TEN DAYS AGO
COMMITTED SHOWED ONLY 41% OF THE
PEOPLE IN WISCONSIN SUPPORT
THE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
ONLY 41%.
THERE'S NOT 41% SUPPORT FOR
TRUMP, YET 41% OF THE PEOPLE
SAY -- 49% TO SAY THIS IS A
BUNCH OF GARBAGE.
>> Sean: LAST, MATT GAETZ,
TELL US HOW THIS WILL PLAY OUT.
>> WELL, IF WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
GET HUNTER BIDEN BEFORE THE
HOUSE COMMITTEES, I HOPE FOR
UPCOMING GUEST, SENATOR GRAHAM,
WILL BRING HIM BEFORE THE
SENATE, RIGHT ALONGSIDE THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
THAT WILL REALLY BLOW THE TOP OF
THIS ENTIRE SCAM.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THE CIRCUS